I was a kid this is my favorite place in
the whole world
I think this would still be my favorite
spot
that's cuz you haven't been anywhere Oh
so where's better than this then Paris
Plus Delfino ponder if I shut my eyes
now I know exactly how it feels to be in
that little square so let's go we could
get on the Eurostar right now you don't
get it Clark I want to be in Paris as me
the old me there she goes full of me
take time something good sir
use the time he's got left show him how
good his life can be
please barely left the host in two years
we have tried yes but we haven't
succeeded we'll needs to be allowed to
feel like a man
can I take you somewhere bigger was snow
going on a date with will trainer it's
too baby get the red dress out memory Oh
Lucifer Gogh if you're gonna wear a
dress like that Clark
after wear it with confidence only you
will Traynor who tell a woman had aware
of bloody dress
these plants were fantastic they know
you never would have let nice breasts
earn Antonia focus on the world yeah
yeah well you never would have been
looking at these breasts if you hadn't
been in a wheelchair well of course I
knew you wouldn't you wouldn't you would
have been too busy looking at the lanky
blonds the ones you can smell an expense
account of 40 paces in any way I would
have been over there serving drinks one
of the Invisibles am i right
yes but in my defense I wasn't on yep
you know something Clark you got pretty
much anything that makes me want to get
up in the morning
let's go somewhere anywhere in the world
Stephen me what do you say
say yes well
go on
okay it's got a easy
I caught you can you can do anything
Oh
I don't want you to miss it the things
of someone else think of you I have
become a whole new person because of him
- Santa shoo Aswad + - v damn it
you can mist on user he's funny this is
- an odd fellow to him come to Canada's
North us part and even public video
glücklich the sightings over net signs
you didn't